alexander skarsgard is opening up about
being shackled by his sexiness
same girl yeah
same i can't even do this
you must know sam i'm telling you it's a
burden uh but first the actor hit the
red carpet premiere for his new film the
northman in london and had this to say
about keeping up with his fitness amidst
the grueling shoe conditions
it's a tough movie to shoot because it's
a big movie with three 400 people on and
we're crawling around in the mud so it
it it wasn't easy figuring that out but
um i
when we shut down i didn't know whether
it was going to be no one knew whether
it was going to be three weeks or three
months or five months and
so obviously i had to just yeah keep up
the training of the diet
and just wait for that call to be ready
now as we mentioned earlier during the
press tour for the film alex shared why
it's not easy being really really
ridiculously good looking during an
interview with the sunday time saying i
don't really know if that was the reason
i wasn't getting roles uh yeah and he
goes on to say after my first job i was
on a stupid sexy hunky hot list and then
people didn't take you seriously if you
if you want characters with depth but
have been labeled a dude who takes his
shirt off you're not going to get those
offers of course garsgaard has since
cemented his serious actor status by
winning an emmy golden globe sag and
critics choice award for his role in big
little lies where we should point out he
played a man who also happened to be
extremely conventionally attractive so
what do you think of alex's comments and
you saw northman was that his
moment of of a serious role was he
everything he i don't know if he would
call it a serious role it's i mean he's
like a viking type guy who you know out
for revenge for his father it's it's
it's that kind of thing right it's not
it's not a serious dramatic role or
anything like that
uh it was it he started off in a real
tough place um alexander and joe
meganello both started off in real tough
places which is you know before true
blood nobody really knew who alexander
was and he showed up looking the way he
did and did too many seasons of that
show with no shirt on and so that's how
we were all introduced to him and when
you're introduced to somebody that way
it's really difficult to put them or to
allow them pamela anderson went through
the same thing yeah that is how we met
pam anderson and she fought against it
for her entire career and this is
probably something that he's gonna have
to fight but what about brad pitt like
jody our uh our producer was also
telling us about the fact that he
started with being shirtless and people
have done serious actions
patrick swayze the best example uh i
just want to leave with this no nicole
said i'd crawl around in the mud with
him so listen he's very very sexy he
knows he hears you